[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAULIN PATEL: Welcome to
"Making AI/ML Simple, Fast,
and Cost-effective with
Google Kubernetes Engine."
My name is Maulin Patel.
I am the Product
Manager at Google Cloud.
And I am very
pleased to introduce
our distinguished colleague
from BHGE Digital, Mahadevan
and Murali.
MAHADEVAN BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Thanks, Maulin.
Hi, my name is Mahadevan.
I am a Principal Data
Scientist at BHGE Digital.
I'm a mechanical
engineer and have
a deep focus in working
on system-level modeling
and building analytics.
MURALI KARUMURI:
Hello, good afternoon.
I know it's right after lunch.
And a little nap makes
it easy and nice,
but it's Kubernetes, OK?
It's exciting.
OK, let's get started.
Anyway, I am Murali.
I am a Principal Analytics
Advocate with BHGE.
My primary focus is on
data and infrastructure.
I work with the customers
basically in moving the data to
on prem, or cloud, wherever it
is, and making it consumable,
and then handing it off to the
data scientists like Mahadevan
to do their magic.
Thank you.
MAULIN PATEL: Thank
you, both of you.
So let's get started.
So today, we are going to
talk about two hot topics
in the computer industry.
First is artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
And second is Kubernetes.
Both are critical pillars
in today's modern computing
environment.
In today's digital economy,
data is the currency.
For many of us, data is the
lifeblood of our company.
And we want to convert data
into meaningful information,
actionable intelligence.
AI/ML is the engine that
helps us convert the data
into actionable intelligence.
And with the actionable
intelligence,
we can make better
business decisions
and drive actions
in our organization.
Industries all around the world
are investing very heavily
into AI/ML capabilities.
At Google, our mission is
to make AI/ML simple, fast,
and cost-effective.
We want to make AI/ML simple so
everyone in your organization
can benefit from it.
We want to make
AI/ML fast so you
can build a model fast,
train them fast, deploy them
fast, and get insight faster.
We also want to make
AI/ML cost-effective
in order to democratize
AI/ML so that it's
accessible to everyone.
So when we think about
AI/ML, we typically
think about building
models and training models.
But in reality, AI/ML involves
a lot more than building
and training models.
Typically the AI/ML code
is a very small part
of the end-to-end
AI/ML tool chain.
We need to recognize that
AI/ML is a team sport.
A lot of skills
are needed in order
to build end-to-end
AI/ML application.
For example, a data
engineer may gather the data
and clean the data.
Another engineer may extract
feature out of the data.
A data scientist
may build a model.
An application engineer
may convert the model
into application APIs.
And an end user may use the
model built using those APIs.
So anyone who has ever
tried to build an AI/ML team
knows that there is a
shortage of AI/ML skills.
So how can we make these scarce
resources 10x more productive?
How can we give them
an environment that
helps them innovate faster?
That's why we have built a
cloud-native AI/ML platform.
So world is moving towards
cloud-native computing.
And Kubernetes is
the de facto standard
for orchestrating
containerized workload.
We have brought the
power of Kubernetes
to the world of AI/ML.
Kubernetes makes AI/ML
workflows simple, composable,
and scalable.
With the help of
Kubernetes platform,
a data scientist can
train and deploy a model
without having to worry about
underlying infrastructure.
Simply choose your
favorite AI/ML framework,
pack the model up
into containers,
and deploy them on
Kubernetes at scale.
Kubernetes will
scale your models
from a single node
to thousands of nodes
depending on your
compute requirement.
It will make you
more productive.
And the best part is you will
be able to reproduce results
reliably across the platform.
So let's think about why
Kubernetes is an ideal platform
for building AI/ML tool chain.
So there are three
core reasons why.
First is portability.
Kubernetes enables
cloud-native open standard API
which means you
can seamlessly port
your workload between
cloud, and laptop,
and your own private data
center without having
to change your source code.
Number two, it makes
your workload scalable.
You can scale from a single
node to thousands of nodes.
Also Kubernetes supports
hardware accelerators
such as GPUs and
TPUs and provides you
high-level abstractions
like auto scaling or auto
provisioning which makes
scaling your workload
super simple and easy.
And number three
is productivity.
With the help of Kubernetes,
you can free up your users
from managing their
own workstations or VM.
As a data scientist
and data engineer,
you can focus on your
core mission which
is to basically build
and deployment models
without having to worry about
underlying infrastructure.
So if you are a data
scientist, you are wondering,
do I have to master the
Kubernetes skill in order
to benefit from
all these features?
Great news, you don't have
to master those skills.
Data scientists typically
build their model
inside the Notebooks.
They have their preferences
for their libraries and machine
learning frameworks.
To make their work
super simple and easy,
we are providing
hosted Notebooks.
And our hosted Notebooks
are pre-configured with one
of the widely-used
libraries like Pandas
and also many other
machine learning
frameworks like TensorFlow,
Keras, and many, many more.
All you have to do is
open up your browser,
connect to your data,
and start building models
inside your Notebooks.
The best part is, you
can train the model
and deploy your model
on the top of Kubernetes
directly from your Notebook.
You don't even have
to leave the Notebook.
So you get very
Notebook-friendly experience
and all the benefits
of Kubernetes.
So what if you are an
expert Kubernetes user?
Great news, Kubernetes
also provides you
high level abstraction that
helps you run TensorFlow jobs
very simply and easily.
For example, you can
make use of TFJob.
What the TFJob does
is it integrates
TensorFlow distributor
training and estimator
APIs with Kubernetes.
And it allows you to scale
training and leverage
the hardware accelerators
which work with Kubernetes.
As a user, you can benefit
from a very vibrant ecosystem
of Kubernetes products
that are out there when
you work and develop your
models on the top of Kubernetes.
You can use Kubernetes
dashboards for monitoring
or Prometheus, and Grafana,
and many, many other tools
which community have
developed over many years.
So Kubernetes also
makes TensorFlow
serving super simple and easy.
So let's say you build a
very sophisticated movie
recommendation engine.
Now you want to test your
model on a small scale
with the global traffic.
Now, if you deploy
your model in US,
the traffic will
be overwhelmingly
from the audience which
loves Hollywood movie.
If you deploy this
model in India,
the traffic will be
from overwhelmingly
from the audience which
loves Bollywood movie.
So you have a dilemma.
On the one hand, you
want to test your model
through a global
cross-section of the traffic.
On the other hand,
you don't want
to deploy your model
globally, which-- because it's
an experimental model.
And you are concerned
about the blast radius
of something going wrong.
So what do you do?
Here again, Kubernetes and
Istio you come to the rescue.
With the help of
Kubernetes and Istio
you can actually configure
the your load balancer
so that your model
gets a cross section
of the traffic from many,
many different regions.
So you can test the fidelity of
your model across the regions
without having to deploy
your model globally.
So what it means is Kubernetes
helps you address many model
roll out challenges.
It makes model lifecycle
management super
simple and easy.
So so far, I talked
about how Kubernetes
simplifies model building.
But the biggest challenge
is model training.
We have seen time and time
that building a complex model
takes really, really long
time, mainly because it takes
a very long time to train them.
So in order to expedite
the model training,
we have brought the power
of GPUs to the Kubernetes.
So with the help of
GPUs, you can turbo
charge your compute-intensive
applications.
We support a wide range of GPUs
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
And they have a different cost
versus performance profile,
so you can choose the GPU that
best suits your application
needs and your budget.
You can get started with a
Kubernetes GPU K80, which
we support, which gives
you entry-level performance
at a lower cost.
But if you decide to turbo
charge your application,
you can use V100, which
is very powerful GPU
and allows you to expedite
your model building,
and model training, as
well as model serving.
And the best part is that GKE
also supports preemptible GPU.
So for your batch workload,
you can reduce the cost
by 50% to 70% by using
pre-emptible GPUs.
So we also offer you many
more choices for hardware
accelerators to accelerate
your machine learning workload.
So for example, on
Google Cloud GKE,
we also support Google
Design hardware accelerators
which we call Cloud
TPU, which will further
accelerate your AI/ML workload
while reducing the cost.
And I am super
pleased to announce
that our third generation
Cloud TPUs, version three,
are now generally available
on Google Kubernetes
Engine starting today.
So you can access those
very powerful Cloud TPUs use
just like you will access
CPUs and GPUs on GKE.
You don't have to
manage them on your own.
Google Kubernetes Engine
actually manages them for you.
Also, the best part,
they are available
as a preemptible load, which
means you can substantially
reduce the cost
of batch training
by using preemptible Cloud TPUs.
Google Kubernetes Engine also
supports cluster auto scaler
with GPU and TPUs.
So with the help of
cluster auto scaler,
you can automatically scale
up and down the clusters
for best performance over cost.
So nodes with GPU and
TPU get created when you
need extra compute capacity.
You don't have to
manually schedule them.
And the nodes with GPU and TPU
get deleted when they are idle.
So you get two core features,
on demand extra compute
without you having to
manually scheduled them,
and number two, freeing up the
resources when they are not
used, which means you
don't have to pay for them.
So it optimizes the cost and
gives you a super computing
powers without manual work.
Now let's look at a
real-world example.
What would be a better example
than a software program
that defeated world champions
and professional Go players?
This was a historical
milestone in the history
of artificial intelligence when
a software program defeated
world champions.
So for those who are
familiar with Go,
Go is a strategy board
game which was invented
more than 2,500 years ago.
And ever since, it has
captivated the human mind.
It is played on
a 19-by-19 board.
And players actually
alternate placing the stones
on an empty cross-section.
And the player that surrounds
more territory actually wins.
So Go is incredibly
difficult program
for a computer to learn.
And here is why.
Just imagine that the number
of board configurations that
are possible on a Go
board are actually more
than the number of
atoms in the universe,
number of atoms in the universe.
So just a brute force
approach does not work.
Number two, for every move,
you have too many choices
available.
And its impact is realized
over a large horizon which
makes this very, very
difficult for a computer
to analyze through.
And number three,
unlike chess which
has rules when the game
is over, for example,
one player checkmates
the other, Go
has no rule where it dictates
the termination of a game.
Game is over when
two parties agree,
which means it's very
difficult for a computer
to analyze when
the game is over.
So AlphaGo Zero was
the first program
which defeated the
professional Go player.
And I'm going to
talk about Minigo,
which is an open-source
independent implementation
of the AlphaGo Zero.
So let's see how Go
algorithm is implemented.
So Minigo Gore is
actually implemented using
reinforced learning algorithm.
So in reinforced learning,
there are two critical steps.
In the first step, the
model plays against itself,
which is called a self-play.
And it records the search
space for every move.
In the second
step, the data that
is gathered in the first step
is used to train the model
and make the model better.
Now again, this better
model plays against itself
to create more data.
And this more data is used
to create even better models.
So this loops keeps repeating.
And model gets better,
and better, and better.
Now remember, every Go
game has hundreds of moves.
And for every move, the
model has to do inference
for thousands of search spaces.
So the amount of compute
that is needed for inference
actually dwarfs the amount of
compute needed for training.
So inference is the
biggest bottleneck.
You can see in this
picture, self-play arrow
is much bigger than
the training arrow.
It's on purpose.
So how can we
basically make sure
that this game can be trained
in a short amount of time?
So the great news here
is that all these games
can be played independently
in parallel because they
are completely independent.
So using that, we
implemented the Minigo
on the top of GKE,
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And initial implementation
used to take more than a couple
of months to train.
Now imagine you want to
experiment with that,
you start training, and then it
says, come back in five months
and the training will be over.
That would be quite
frustrating, isn't it?
So with the help
of Cloud TPUs, we
could scale down
the training time
on the top of Google
Kubernetes Engine
to just a couple of days.
So after we fully
trained it, the model
used to play millions of
games and every single day.
Every second, 15 to
13 games can be played
with this advanced feature.
We could devote up to
150 petaflops of compute
to a single problem very easily.
So Cloud TPUs are incredibly
powerful machines.
So this is a picture of
Cloud TPU version two.
And we used it to train a very
well-known model, which is
ResNet-50, on ImageNet dataset.
And with one single Cloud
TPU which has eight core,
we could train the
entire ResNet-50 model
in under nine hours.
And the best part was the total
cost was a little under $39.
And if we use a preemptible TPU,
the cost was almost one third
to a little under $13.
So in $13, you have a
supercomputer at your disposal
to train a very complex model.
Isn't that incredible?
And with version three and using
many, many chips in parallel,
in this case 1,024
chips in parallel,
we could train a ResNet-50
model on ImageNet dataset up
to 76.3% accuracy
in just 2.2 minutes.
It's just blowing to
think that this machine.
Could process one million
images per second, more than one
million.
That's just amazing you could
train models in two minutes
by the time you
drink your coffee.
So it will save
you so much time.
You can do so much
more with your time,
do something interesting instead
of waiting for model to finish.
So in order to help you
get started quickly,
Google provides many open-source
references for Cloud TPUs.
And with this
open-source references,
you can solve many
real-life problems.
For example, you can create
image recognition algorithms.
Or you can create
machine translation,
or do speech recognition,
or image relation,
or many, many different things.
All you have to do
is bring your data,
use the existing
model to train them.
And you're on a great start.
But if you choose to decide
to work on a special problem,
you can always write
something from scratch
using the libraries
that are made available.
And we support many, many
different frameworks,
so you can get started with
all the tutorials and knowledge
that is built in the community
about TensorFlow, Keras,
and many, many
different frameworks.
So now let's hear from BHGE
Digital about their experience
and their journey of building
AI/ML algorithms and models
on the top of Kubernetes--
Mahadevan?
MAHADEVAN BALASUBRAMANIAM:
Thanks, Maulin.
So in this portion
of the presentation,
we'll actually go over
our team's experience
with using GKE.
In particular, we will share
some of the best practices
that we followed so that we
can actually leverage all
the resources we commission.
And it's actually simple,
fast, and cost-effective.
So just to give a scale
of the type of problems
that we as a larger GE face.
In every two seconds,
a plane with the GE
takes off somewhere
in the world.
Nearly 30% of the
world's electricity
is actually made
by a GE turbine.
Coming more closer to
home, we are Baker Hughes.
We are an oil and gas company.
So this is the world's
first full-stream company
which actually takes care
of exploring oil, extracting
oil, transporting
and refining all
the way through the
entire lifecycle of oil.
So in order to sort of manage
all these assets properly,
we have to deal with
a lot of models.
You're talking of
thousands of models.
For us, a model
is something which
links inputs to its outputs.
So how do you sort of
build these models?
So in this case, we
leverage the same framework
that Maulin mentioned, where
we use GKE that is sitting
on top of the hardware layer.
And we utilize the framework
that we first kind of started
off at Baker Hughes called
the Dependent Docker.
So this helps an
analytics engineer
to package their
analytics into containers.
So it gives a sequence
of scripts and a process
that can help institutionalize
how analytics could be built,
run, tested, and deployed.
So all the analytics
would be actually packaged
as containers.
And that would actually
feed applications
that you see at the top.
So the applications would
range from data management.
We deal with a
lot of data, which
we'll talk about soon, also
a lot of other applications
where we deal with
anomaly detection
just to find if a system is
operating normal or abnormal,
is it time to shut it down or
do some preventative action
over it.
There are lots of other
concepts of applications
where we deal with the amount
of remaining useful life
that a part has, and definitely,
optimizing the operation.
In order to do this, we need
to have all these applications.
And now let us look at what is
a cost of a false prediction.
A false prediction in our
case can actually mean we need
to shut down a plant, or
probably we need to sort
of tell a plane cannot take off.
And it'll be stuck
at the tarmac.
The results are
pretty cost-sensitive.
And we are going
to actually lose
a lot of money in the process.
Therefore, we strive
a lot to actually get
very accurate models.
So how do you build
accurate models?
We do have, to build, say,
for a model for a small asset,
we're looking at
around a five or six
engineers who spend
around a month or two
to make a model that
is pretty accurate.
Now, if we were to scale it for
an entire plant or a refinery,
I'm talking about
thousands of models.
No way this model can be scaled.
Or this traditional way
of bringing in more people
and trying to sort of
build models cannot scale.
And on the other flip
side, it is not as simple
as commissioning more
nodes and clicking a button
and say go for the
models to be created.
So we need to do something
different and proper
to use, leverage all the
machines that we commission.
So what we will highlight in
the subsequent presentations
are the things, the bottlenecks
that are there in the process,
and how we overcame
that so that we
will be able to build
these models at scale
while still being
cost-effective.
So let us focus on
the first example
where we look at the
data wrangling exercise.
So we deal with a
lot of data here.
So we take a simple refinery,
we are looking at our own 3,000
sensors or so.
That is generating data the
sensors can be generating data
at different rates.
It can be in seconds.
Some can be in minutes,
a few seconds, et cetera.
So all these data
has to be connected.
And therefore, for
the 3,000 sensors,
over a two-year
period, we are talking
about trillion rows of data.
This is pure, raw data.
And this raw data needs
to be sort of converted
into some workable data that
can be fed into the analytic.
And so you can also
expect different--
analytics would need the
data at different rates.
So you need to prepare
different sets of data
to feed different analytics.
And moreover, all the
raw data that we get
would not be really clean.
It has to be cleaned
for some missing data
because somebody forgot
to turn on the switch
to record the data, or some
wire got tripped over time.
So we need to go and
clean up the data,
fill in the missing data so that
it can be prepared in a form
that it can be used by
the downstream analytics.
So the working dataset
that we deal with
can be of the order
of 1.8 trillion rows.
And therefore, that is a
lot of data to deal with.
So how do we sort of
handle it at scale?
So let us look at
the case of the graph
that I have shown here
to explain the concept.
So there are two
axes in the graph.
The vertical axis is
called the capability axis.
It's actually telling how
fast of a processor you have,
how good of a CPU you have.
So the further north or
further up I go along the axis,
I am sort of going towards
a supercomputer realm.
And I am sort of
saturating the process.
What is on the horizontal axis
is called the capacity machine
where we actually can
increase our capacity
or keep capacity by
scaling out the machines,
and commissioning more
resources, and using them.
In the case of
data wrangling, we
are going to process it
typically at a tag-wise level,
meaning each tag can be taken.
It can be filled in
for the missing data
or reassembled to go
and get its answer.
Or we can deal with
a group of tags
because there are some
things that physics governs.
For example, a heat exchanger,
the temperature sensor in it
is going to be in sync with
the ambient temperature that's
being measured outside.
I cannot treat them
as independent,
so they are going to deal with
sensors by itself or a group
of sensors that we would know
a priori based on the physics.
In either case, this process
is pretty well-optimized.
That's why to
process a single tag
or a per-tag cost,
which I have indicated
by the circle over there,
is almost further north
in the vertical axis,
and I've indicated
by the circle over there.
Next if I were to get a certain
target performance where
we say we want to finish
this particular inline
operation in a few
hours, that positions
where our target performance
for in-tags has to go.
In order to do
that, we can come up
with how many machines
we have to scale out
to achieve the performance.
Later on, Murali
will actually show
a demo of how we were
able to achieve scale up
with different nodes.
And he will specify the cost and
the speed tradeoff over there.
Next we will actually focus
on the deep-learning example.
Any deep-learning
model will actually
go through a process of
an architectural search
so that we can actually
get the best model.
We are striving 'till the last
mile but get an accurate model,
because the cost of
a false prediction
is pretty steep for
the industrial case.
How is it typically done?
A subject matter expert
would take and sample
different regions.
He would decide based on how
the model is moving around
how we could tune the number of
layers, what kind of a dropout
we need to use, and other
activation parameters.
So in the case of
BHGE, in order,
if you're going to build
thousands of models,
we have automated this
process, where we start off
with sample space that is
indicated by the red crosses
that you see over there.
We train the deep-learning
models in the space.
And we take the results.
And we actually are going
to look at certain outcomes
from those models
with which we actually
use to fit the model with
those being the outputs,
and the inputs being
those red crosses.
That's a meta
model that we built
which can be very
quickly queried
for other architectures
that are derived from that.
We go and search the space
of the meta model, which
is a surrogate
model, and come up
with the blue set of
dots which is actually
[INAUDIBLE] that
indicates the best choices
for the next pass of runs.
So from that blue
curve, we can pick
a couple of dots and
re-learn the process, couple
it along with the original
red x's to refine the model,
and keep on continuing
the process.
So as you can see, this process
is an iterative process.
You start off with the red x's.
You come up with your
best candidates, which
are sitting in your blue curve.
You then again refine the model.
You go again to the red curve.
And you keep on pushing
the process 'till
then, 'till the point
where you're sort of happy
or you have enough
tradeoff to the cost
versus the amount of effort
you're able to put in.
So in this case,
what you see here,
we looked at a
deep-learning model
which had around a 10-plus
architecture parameters
that we had to tune.
We actually searched over a
quarter-million architectures.
And the proof of the pudding is
actually in the results we get.
So the final answer that
we got out of this process,
we actually had a 10x
improvement in the training
effectiveness over a model that
was done by a random search
by a subject matter expert.
Next we'll look at how we
dealt with some of the process
bottlenecks and
how we like removed
them to get the full speed
that we really need to achieve.
So first we'll start
looking at the containers.
As we said, we build
a lot of containers.
And that's the box that
we show over there.
And our containers
are encapsulating
different analytics.
So it can be with
different complexity.
So some containers
might need GPUs,
might utilize them only for
a small level, say, 20%, 30%.
Others might saturate
it completely.
So therefore, we need--
or the containers can actually
have much bigger footprint.
So if I were to restart
the container every time
I'm going to make a run, I'm
going to incur a big startup
time for the container.
If that is a bottleneck
in your building process,
we could overcome that
by starting the container
as a service, where
we can actually
run an infinite loop to
maintain the container active.
We can exit into the container,
and sort of run the process,
and get the answer back.
So that's how we can
overcome situations
where the containers
actually have
a much larger start-up time.
The second, we need to move
data into the container
and outside the container
to build models.
Typically the training
data is pretty big.
So we don't want
to copy information
into the containers.
The way in which we do
it is via map drive.
So we are avoid copying huge
files into the container
and bringing it out.
And all the input and output
that, as I said before,
are pretty well-structured--
so the output we deal with
are the outcomes that
we want from the model.
Those are all
exposed as JSON files
that we'll be able to
track and move it out.
So that's how we
handle the data.
And finally, more
importantly, as I said,
each container is not going
to be using all the resources
to its fullest potential.
I should not assign
this continue
to run on this particular GPU.
So what we do here
in this case is,
we actually run a max
case of the container
so that we can determine
how much GPU it utilizes
and how much memory it utilizes.
Knowing that, we'll be
able to use the fact
and schedule multiple containers
to actually run on the same GPU
so that we'll be able to max
out the GPU that we commission.
So if you sort of
look at the graph,
I have just intentionally
shown the blue dot
to be on the lower left just
to indicate conceptually
that this analytic does not use
the GPU all by itself fully.
So how do you sort of go up
further north and to the east?
We can actually use the
fractional resource utilization
to go up north and use
more number of GPUs
to go further towards the
right and go towards the star.
So that is how we'll
be able to achieve
the best performance
with all the resources
that we commission.
Next we will look at the aspect
of orchestrating containers.
So the entire process was
pretty iterative, as I said.
And so the way in
which it starts
is we have a node
which will decide
what are the next
iterations I need to spawn.
So it spawns the next set of
iterations, after which it
actually has to
collate the results
and decide if I have to
continue with the next set
of iterations.
And those intermediate levels
are actually made stateful
so that I can make a
decision whether I need
to continue further or not.
And one of the things
that we noticed
was, like, there is
a limitation of a
for loop inside the Kubeflow.
So we had to
actually unravel it.
And we made it in a form
where we spawn, we accumulate.
We again spawn.
We accumulate the
process to continue it
and get the results.
So in order to sort of
reach the full potential
of all the resources
we commission,
we had to use this
fractional GPU allocation
so that we can get a near linear
scale up for the resources
that we have.
I will quickly show
the results at the end
after Murali finishes his talk.
Thanks.
MURALI KARUMURI: Yeah,
thanks, Mahadevan.
As Mahadevan said, we are
an oil and gas industry.
And we are not a
digital native industry.
There is a vast difference
between digital native industry
and an oil and gas industry.
Usually the data we get
from digital native industry
is rich.
And it is almost ready
to be consumable.
But in oil and gas
industry, we collect
the data over last 30 years.
And it can be very messy.
And very often, we don't even
know what we are looking for,
unless we explore.
So the exploration
stage of the data
itself is quite different from
the digital native industries.
And it is highly iterative.
And we have to iterate so
many times 'till the data
scientists come back
and say that, yes, now
the data is consumable.
So I mean, some of you
maybe like me, maybe
from a traditional
data background,
and scale up was the solution.
But now we have scale out.
And Kubernetes really comes
as a great rescuer here.
OK, so here I would
like to show--
I mean, so for the last couple
of years or more than that,
we have been a very
heavy Kubernetes shop.
And we use Kubernetes
extensively, both on prem
and on various cloud platforms.
And we have a
heterogeneous environment.
So we have been managing this
Kubernetes clusters on prem.
And some of the
challenges-- and some of you
know that the batch management
is the biggest hassle.
And we need to take downtime.
And we need to go back
to the data scientists.
And Mahadevan will
be very frustrated
that we bring
these clusters down
in the middle of a big
exploration model development.
And the two other [INAUDIBLE],,
what we have seen so far
is the auto scaling.
Auto scaling is not available.
I mean, it's not so easy
to implement it on prem.
And then the cost--
OK, it's not cost-effective.
If you are fixed
with 100 nodes, you
have to continue to
consume all the 100 nodes.
Then we started recently
migrating to GCP.
And we have been using GKE.
Here the biggest advantage, as
you can see on the dashboard
here, this has
been made possible
because we used
Stackdriver on GCP.
So we collect the metrics
at the granular level.
And this is in fact a
cluster of clusters.
And we can immediately see
which node is coming up
and which node is being
shutdown, is being spun down.
And so we can
continuously monitor it.
This is made possible only
because we run it on GCP.
The other aspect is the
management of the cluster.
Now, we don't have to worry.
We have a small dev ops team.
And they are now relieved.
And Mahadevan can spend more
time on his model development
rather than maintaining
the clusters.
The third aspect is cost.
Because we provision them
whenever it's needed,
we don't spend as much money
as we used to do before.
I will have a simple demo here.
Before we go to the demo,
let me explain here.
So we took a simple
query, one of the simplest
of simple queries as soon
as we received the data.
That's about 55 billion rows.
And when we ran
it with 10 nodes,
it was costing
typically, like, $1.
And when we scale
it up to 40, nodes
we finished the job in 130
seconds as against 700 seconds.
And the cost came down by 28%.
So this is where we
become a differentiator,
because we finished the
job in far less time.
And we achieve it at
far less cost as well.
So this is the--
I hope the demo
gods will help me.
Right, so as you
can see, this is
a cluster of [INAUDIBLE] nodes.
And this is the
running average, one
of the simplest
of simple queries
that we do as soon as
we receive the raw data
from the customers.
So we can see the
progress of the query.
It's against 40 nodes.
Sorry, yeah, I
just refreshed it.
And let me forward it
in the interest of time.
So as you can see here,
it's 55 billion rows.
55 billion rows, we
could complete it
in two minutes and nine seconds.
And the cost of the
query is less than $1.
That's what we achieved.
And this is against
55 billion rows.
And as Mahadevan said, typically
for a simple equipment,
what it would make, it--
when we expand it, it goes
to 1.8 trillion records.
So we experiment this with
the less number of nodes.
And then as the need
arises, we scale up.
And that's how we achieve
at the cheaper rate.
Thanks, Mahadevan.
MAHADEVAN BALASUBRAMANIAM:
OK, so I'll quickly
summarize the results from
the auto scaling experiment
that we did.
So where we actually take--
look at the graph
over here, where
we are trying to increase
the number of GPUs.
And we can sort of see
whether we're able to leverage
and utilize it
completely at all.
So look at the
bottom two graphs.
So what you see on the right
side is the number of GPU nodes
where we are doing
an experiment where
we are able to
actually increase,
or in a preset manner,
the number of GPU
goes from one, to two, to
three, all the way 'till eight.
And what you see
on the left side,
the lower left is
actually telling how
we are able to utilize the GPU.
So we start off with
one GPU beginning.
And then we ramp
it from one to two.
You can immediately see the
percentage utilization drops
to 50.
And it again kicks up and
almost goes up instantaneously
to 100%.
The next step, again,
go from two to three,
you can sort of see it ducking
down and again goes up 100%.
So the main takeaway
from here is
the way in which we did
the fractional utilization
and were able to
[INAUDIBLE] to the GPUs,
we were able to nearly
assign full utilization as we
increase the number of GPUs.
And more importantly, as
we take the GPUs away,
we are also able
to ramp it down.
So this one just
summarizes how we're
able to show auto scaling
works when we ramp up
and ramp down the GPUs.
The next case is how we actually
make it work on the GKE.
So in this experiment,
what we did was,
we had a 32-node cluster.
And instead of actually
allowing the cluster
to operate or go up to
100%, we preset the limit
that it reaches, so to 80%.
So once we load up the
machine, as was sort of shown
by the experiment one, and
because we are capping it
off at 80%, the number
of node requirement
actually jumps instantaneously
from 32 to all the way to 40.
It's pretty much flat.
And once the load tapers
down, it leaves us the GPUs
and comes back again.
Just to see the
repeatability, we again
fired the process again.
So that is the
experiment two, where
we fired the same process
with the same constraints, 80%
as your threshold.
And as you can
see, the GPU nodes
that got commissioned
automatically actually
increased to 40.
And then it came down.
For the third
experiment what we did
was, we wanted to simulate a
case where we partially permit
an increase, and then
due to some other case,
we're actually taking the
GPUs way from the system too.
So we capped it off initially
to some intermediate number
and then slowly started removing
the GPUs from the system
to see how it responds.
As you can see, it
got capped over there.
And we brought down the
GPUs in a preset sequence
in the bottom right.
As you can see at
the top, the time
it took to sort of complete
the entire process actually
expanded along the horizontal.
So again, in order to maintain
a high GPU utilization,
we need to have a good
way of orchestrating
and need to design the
underlying containers
to respect that,
and so that you will
be able to leverage it fully.
So in summary, if I were toward
summarize the best practices,
the cloud scalability
actually requires
a lot of planning on how
you build the containers,
how you understand
how much resources
it needs and manage it.
And definitely look for a lot
of redesign and iterative steps
that needs to happen.
And finally, for load balancing,
the fractional GPU utilization
and other things has to
be adhered to so that they
can use the resources fully.
MURALI KARUMURI:
Thanks, Mahadevan.
I'd like to say a
couple of things here.
Scaling up is not finished yet.
I mean, it can be--
sometimes it will end
up as a brute force.
And it is highly iterative.
A lot of patience and
planning is required.
And load balancing
is another aspect.
You've got to think
about it very carefully.
And adaptive space, be prepared
to have some space so that you
can redesign your architecture
and take a different route,
a totally different route
than from where you started.
It's not easy.
I mean, now that
you have Kubernetes,
and particularly, GKE, it's
made it much more simpler.
Now for example, scaling up
is much more simple right now.
For example, a typical
scaling up about 200 nodes,
it happens in less
than a minute.
So you've got to have a lot of
space to adapt to the changes.
But you can do a lot of
things with Kubernetes, yeah.
MAULIN PATEL: Thank you, Murali.
Thank you Mahadevan
and Murali for sharing
your insightful
experiences with us today.
So let's summarize
the key takeaways.
So at Google, our
mission is very simple.
We want to empower your
team to drive innovation
by making AI/ML simple,
fast, and cost-effective.
We are making AI/ML simple
by offering data scientists
their friendly notebooks.
We are freeing them up from
managing the infrastructure
and also providing higher level
abstractions like TensorFlow
jobs and TensorFlow servings
so that their work becomes
super simple.
We are making AI/ML fast by
offering you on-demand scale up
and scale down, and also
hardware accelerators
like GPUs and TPUs.
And we are making AI/ML
cost-effective by making
your teams more productive
with advanced tooling
and avoiding the vendor
locking with open platforms
like Kubernetes, and Kubeflow,
and many other things
we have developed in
Google are available
in open-source environment.
This way you can write
once and run anywhere.
And finally but
most important, you
have preemptible GPUs
and TPUs to further lower
the cost for your
batch workloads.
[MUSIC PLAYING]